[Musique]
chaque année fait une mesure sur les
retraites là nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
une convention nationale qui pendant un
an autour des grands thèmes qui sont
ceux des retraites celui de l'emploi des
seniors des carrières longues de la
pénibilité des pensions de reversion des
régimes spéciaux et si elle n'aboutit
pas nous avons en effet mis des mesures
paramétrées comme le rapport à 64 ans
l'allongement de la loi Touraine donc
cette branchevilliers chaque année nous
y touchons parce que rien ne se fait
rien ne bouge c'est le seul gouvernement
qui ont 5 ans n'a pas fait de régime de
retraite sur la branche famille le PLFSS
prévoyait de soustraire 2 milliards
d'euros de la branche famille pour les
mettre sur l'assurance maladie de ce qui
ne nous satisfait pas du tout nous avons
également encadré la téléconsultation
encadrer l'intérêt et à l'article 23
nous avons remis la proposition de loi
du président Retailleau sur une
quatrième internat et donc beaucoup de
choses ont changé dans ce bel effet 16
beaucoup de mesures sont des mesures
nouvelles
dernier point important nous avons cette
année rejeté l'article qui fixait
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie qu'on appelle la
dame c'est la première fois que nous le
rejetons depuis plusieurs années parce
qu'il nous a semblé totalement insertion
nous avions demandé des chiffres qui
nous sont parvenus très tardivement et
de façon partielle puisque en effet le
Ministre de la Santé annoncée des
mesures notamment pour la pédiatrie pour
les urgences qui ont fait en effet leur
dame 2022 a été rectifiée mais pour 2023
on nous a dit maintenant il y a pas
besoin de rectification de l'article tel
qu'Il vous a été présenté pour cette
raison nous avons rejeté projeté cet
objectif
[Musique]